-Here's how the game works.
One person puts on
these headphones
with loud music playing.
You can play this game at home.
Then the other person
picks up a card,
reads the random phrase
on that card.
And the person wearing
headphones
has to try guess
what they just said.
Okay? Naomi, you can put
the headphones on first.
-Oh, okay. So you're first.
-Yeah.
And I will then read you
my phrase.
I'm going to start
the loud music. Ready?
Can you hear -- can you hear me?
Can you hear me? Ready?
Hmm.
Walkie-talkie.
-Walking turkey.
[ Laughter ]
-Walkie-talkie.
-Walking doggie.
[ Laughter ]
-So close. Walkie-talkie.
-Walking dolly.
[ Laughter ]
It's definitely walking?
No?
-Walkie. "Eee, eee."
Walkie. Walkie-talkie.
Walkie-talkie.
-Rocking dolly.
[ Laughter ]
-Walkie-talk --
Walkie-talkie.
-Slow, please.
-Got you.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't yell at me!
-Okay. Oh, am I yelling?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
Walkie.
-Walking.
[ Laughter ]
-Walkie.
-Walkie. Walkie!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Talkie.
-Doggy.
-Dorky.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm bad. I'm bad.
-I am dorky.
-I failed.
-Walkie-talkie.
-Oh, God.
-Very close. Come on!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-That's --
-That was good. You did great!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, we got to get
at least one.
We got --
-Sorry, that was --
-Oh, wow.
-That was not good.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my. Okay.
Um -- Okay.
Tuna noodle casserole.
[ Laughter ]
-Chiwetel Ejiofor?
-Tuna.
-Do nice.
-Tuna. Tuna. Noodle.
-Doughnuts.
[ Laughter ]
-Tuna noodle.
-Doughnuts.
-No.
-Tuna noodle. Tuna.
-You hear Julie?
[ Laughter ]
-Tuna noodle.
-Do you like to do it?
[ Laughter ]
-Tuna.
-Do you like --
-Drive.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
He's yelling, isn't he?
Tuna. Tuna.
-Doola. Doola?
What is doola?
-No, not doola. Tuna.
T-T-Tuna.
-Tunata.
[ Laughter ]
-Noodle.
-Don't do that to me.
All right. All right.
Stop, all right.
What was it?
-We're terrible.
-What was it?
-I mean, it's a horrible one.
-Let me see what it was.
Tuna noodle casserole?
-Yeah.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-That's impossible.
-I don't even know what that is.
-All right, yeah.
-It sounds awful.
-Yeah, oh, gosh.
All right, here we go.
Gosh, sorry about that.
-Okay.
Sorry, I was a bad teammate.
-Oh, I just took the other one.
I just looked at both of them.
All right,
this will be the last --
this will be the last round.
I'll pick this one.
[ Laughter ]
Hakuna matata.
-Hungry potato.
[ Laughter ]
-Hakuna matata.
-Patata?
Hungry patata.
[ Laughter ]
Hangry. Hangry.
-No, don't say "hangry."
[ Laughter ]
Hangry.
Hakuna.
-Are you?
-Hakuna.
-Ha -- ha --
-Ha. Ha-Ha!
-Ha -- ha -- haku --
haku --
-You.
-Haku--
-Ha--
-Haku --
-Hakuna.
-Haiku?
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-No?
-Hakuna.
-No.
-Haku --
-Na --
-Hakuna. Hakuna!
-Yes.
-Matata!
-Yes!
[ Ding! Ding! Ding! Ding! ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Fantastic!
Come on, buddy, that was it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Naomi Watts!
The champ!
That's how you do it!